[Music]
[Laughter]
turn my lips into a cat's [ __ ]
[Music]
hi I'm Gordon Ramsay hey guys I'm Naisha
Arrington and I'm Paul Ainsworth and
this is snack Wars on lad Bible uh
finally we get to settle a huge debate
because we are professional chefs and
everyone thinks that the U.S snacks are
way better than the English snacks now
I'm of course the final judge because
I'm actually Scottish I'm not English
I'm not American so I'll have the final
say on who has produced the best snack
now a youthful traditional the big
question is are you jam on first or
cream on top interesting the right
answers happening right now great there
you have it why is that so in Devon they
would go cream first then Jam
uh but in Cornwall we go Jam first cream
on top and what am I eating that's on a
biscuit where it's gone
[Laughter]
Naisha
this is what you call food from the gods
this I'm into this no disrespect does it
make any difference whether you're on
top on the bottom there's a cream it
still goes in yeah absolutely but I live
in Cornwall so it makes a huge amount of
difference but why not just put the lid
on turn the [ __ ] thing upside down
yeah you could you could do that but
again stop trying to get me in deep
water the beautiful potted cream English
scone uh up against a Pop-Tart
love these I grew up eating these but I
mean visually it's cream
it's crimpy yeah granddad's toenails
standing next to this look I need to cut
these things for years I don't know why
but my grandma used to get my granddad's
toes every Christmas
seriously
you know what I wish I could have met
your granddad I smell flavor profile
yeah uh to be fair you know it's unfair
I think in a different round it may have
stood a chance but I mean it's against
it if around there's [ __ ] yeah oh you
didn't even fix it yeah any round yeah I
mean I don't want to come on I don't
want it that's an insult to Pop-Tarts no
come on so just try I try a little bit
I'm trying it I try a little bit
[Laughter]
whoa
[Applause]
have a taste
First Impressions what is it it's pork
fat it's basically yeah it's like a but
why does it smell
because we've been in there for 12 years
yeah
wow it smells rancid
but it doesn't when you've had 15 cans
of 10 Etc it makes sense up against
the good old American
beef jerky
I mean
sorry now look at this
that's great
[Music]
got that
yeah it's nice that is a nice snack okay
yeah point the US
yes yes
I love a hot Cheeto this is a snack this
is a USA snack I can get behind it's
spicy
look a little bit more enthusiastic no
because um this isn't the best
representation this is the wrong flavor
it should have been pickled what do you
have here what is that no hold on taste
those first come on they are
this is a classic American snack are you
kidding me that's up against
the monster munch
foreign
I promise they come out quicker to go in
right where are we going Cheetos monster
Munch I'm going with monster Munch all
day Cheetos 100 you know why because the
flavor carries through this it's all up
front and then it dies out I like the
way it levels off gently at that fresh
chili coming true beautiful those really
look that sticky I'm more concerned why
there's only [ __ ] six monster months
it's barely a handful of tight bastards
yeah this one goes to Flaming Cheetos I
have to say that oh dude you know why no
but because
in America we use them we use them for
coating sometimes we Blitz them and
blend them and we we
changed
you have changed Once Upon a Time your
two feet stood in this great land yeah
man now you are you're in Hollywood I
had 25 monster Munch in my [ __ ]
packet back in the 90s Jesus oh wow
okay so this is beautiful white harico
Blanc beans
tomato fondue sauce
[Music]
and here's the nice thing the kind of
things you can do with baked beans yeah
you know Chili's HP Sauce gruya Cheese
congratulated I mean seriously but
everyone in the UK will grow up with
this quick go-to snack
baked beans on Toasties
what the uh what here we are why how not
for me two starches why would I want to
put a bean I can have one or the other
beans on [ __ ] toast yeah but when
you're when you when you're when you're
a student and you've got not much money
you're starving this stuff fills you up
Chef yeah I respect it right but for me
this is new to me I've never experienced
the Bean on a toast no no hold on it's
beans plural more than one we're gonna
fold more than [ __ ] two beans it's
beans multiple beans I'm not saying I
dislike it but um I have a feeling I'm
gonna like this one more
oh oh yeah 100 we got this okay Paul
First Impressions visually what does it
look like
to be fair
yeah this is uh I am a massive fan of an
American hot dog
um Frenchy's ketchup does look good
yeah I'm more [ __ ] up for slicing hot
dog and a half yeah I mean I mean what's
going on there yeah so do you know the
Campo stretching it out and literally
a hot dog food too he sliced the [ __ ]
thing in half you eat a round hot dog
[Music]
Gino
he's downstairs learning again it is
nice I do I do like that that is a that
is a crackling snack everybody makes no
beans on toast but it's it's a good
snack our jewelry's amp it's hot dog
absolutely
right
[Music]
Naisha
he's worth oh fun a Saturday night treat
busy what do you think they look fun I'm
excited I love that there's an array of
little uh colors and flavor profiles the
advert at the time was really good as
well really yeah
I've been strong I can't defend this
because I I hate licorice
I can't say that I've actually had this
scary okay come on toxic waste nuclear
fusion
huh
turn my lips into a cat's [ __ ]
I still can't get mine at the package
honestly oh my God it comes with a
smooth bucket as well I think this is
fair to say it's the liquor store yeah
yeah any day for this game the USA one
yes I told you in your face points Mark
Jesus you okay because Hollywood here
has forgotten his roof is that scum with
the jam on the crazy such a processed
diet but look you that was fresh
ingredients oh my God the scratches I
can still smell of you taking your feet
on your shoes off
have a fresh start because honestly
thanks
um
there's more [ __ ] and stuff going inside
my granddad's cost me back
buddy how would you say that in a in a
lilting English accent jelly tots jelly
tops
laughs
I love how suddenly you said it perfect